[Musique]
des draps qui bouge deschênes qui
symbolise la justice et trois marins qui
porte secours à un naufragé c'est la
scénarisation choisi par le photographe
nicolas henry pour évoquer le drame des
migrants en méditerranée un cliché
réalisé sur l'île de gorée au sénégal
c'est le photographique et fictionnel
mais figurative et un peu à la manière
d'un peintre en fait je suis posé une
sorte de cheval et à l'intérieur je vais
construire tout l'image une oeuvre à
découvrir jusqu'au 6 mars à la
commanderie des templiers à elancourt
dans le cadre de l'exposition cabane
imaginaire et esprits de la nature
quinze ans de voyages à travers le monde
présentée au public avec une démarche
similaire lors de chacune de ces
rencontres évoqué l' intime et le mettre
en scène en utilisant la matière
première présente sur place le moment de
la photographie c'est un moment qui est
très important pour moi parce que c'est
un moment de représentation comme une
représentation théâtrale qui va nous
raconter le monde
l'exposition se poursuit également en
extérieur et dans le choeur de la
chapelle de la commanderie ici se
dévoile une nouvelle fois des clichés
qui pourrait rivaliser avec des toiles
signées des maîtres de la renaissance
la manière dont on a placé ses
photographies contemporaines mais qui
sont présentés comme des peintures
anciennes en fait ça s'intègre et ça
crée vraiment un projet scénographique
je pense car entier
[Musique]
on
homme de théâtre nicolas henry a aussi
réalisé des films d'animation en lien
avec l'écologie cause qui lui tient à
coeur il fait ses cadres photos lui même
avec des encombrants et utilise du bois
de récupération
[Musique]